[Music]
hey what's going on everybody this is
Sean Evans checking in from an all black
room with a table full of hot sauces and
you know what time it is it is time once
again to reveal our season 7 lineup the
cast of characters that will be helping
us terrorize celebrities week in and
week out and for those of you who are
new to the family this is the NBA draft
of hot sauces it's out with the old and
in with the new
after hours of analysis taste testing
we've whittled down our roster to 10 hot
sauces that will be full-court pressing
our guests each and every week over the
last few seasons we've been gradually
cranking up the heat and this season is
no different particularly in the middle
of the lineup but our emphasis this time
around we wanted to make every single
sauce count in terms of heat and in
terms of flavor so we have a wide
variety of peppers from habanero to
ghost Carolina Reaper Trinidad scorpion
pepper X but we're also representing
styles from Louisiana to Mexico India
and back so without further ado let's
introduce you to the new cast of
characters it's the season 7 lineup and
I'm so excited for number one the
classic
it's long been a dream of ours to make
the perfect entry level sauce of course
we tackled the 10th sauce on the board
the hottest with the last dab tried to
make the perfect Midway with lows
calientes but hot ones as a show for
everyone so we wanted to make a sauce
for everyone and tackle it's long been a
dream of ours the tastiest entry-level
sauce in the land this is the classic
made with our friends knowit heat inist
and smokin a dat pucker but it's our
take on the vinegar based Louisiana
style hot sauce genre but the secret
ingredient is a blend of fresh chili de
arbol peppers and apple cider vinegar
some layers that you don't usually see
in an everyday hot sauce it's been
months in the work hundreds of
iterations but finally it's here on the
table such an exciting moment as always
we'll be testing it out on our celebrity
guinea pigs here on the show before we
can get into your hands but this will be
available to the
black in the fall the fall the fall
November maybe andhe number two and
welcome back to the house humble house
San Antonio's humble house is back in
the fold with a guajillo and red
jalapeno number that I'll have you
singing I like it like that
our hot sauce guru NOAA calls it Mexican
sriracha and he's not wrong about that
red jalapeno is a little savory bite of
fresh garlic a kiss of sweetness from
the guajillo peppers and you already
know how I feel about squeeze bottle
technology alright at number three it's
butterfly bakery representing the great
state of Vermont in the three hole
coming through with one of the most
interesting flavor profiles that we've
ever had on hot ones
thanks to maple wood smoked onions say
that with me maple wood smoked onions
it's smoky it's tangy take a look at the
label it is farm-to-table this sauce is
great on a bagel with cream cheese and
smoked salmon you can thank me later
spice Lords but we can't stop the train
just now because coming up in the four
hole our cleanup hitter small axe mango
habanero from small axe peppers bring in
some Southeast Asian vibes to the
proceedings
you might recognize them as the same
maker who made our Bronx green market
sauce in season five here they're
cranking things up a couple notches with
habaneros you know must sucker for that
sweet heat thing so here you have that
mango sweetness you have that habanero
smoke welcome back to the party the BX
and at number five holding it down los
calientes another of our collaborations
with heat inist
autumn may be upon us spice Lords but
the summer lives on a little Louis
Caliente sand you'll feel like you're on
a beach in tulum cracking one open with
a shirtless Bert Kreischer smoky
Serrano's tart tomatillo to be back in
Malibu
anyway the Train moves on and now at
number six we welcome to the lineup
Clark and Hopkins asam bringing some
northern Indian flavors to the mix this
sauce is really cool if you're looking
for something different it has the
warming notes of tamarind and mustard
seeds that you get from a good
curry but also some serious heat with
the ghost peppers and the seven pot
primo it's giving me flashbacks to my
fall curry challenge with rhett and Link
but I'll be damned if it ain't delicious
on some wings alright starting to heat
things up here at number seven colles
firewater which comes from New Zealand
has the words [ __ ] hot written right
on the bottle if there's not a pray for
Shawn hashtag on the screen right now I
think it's safe to say that hot ones
staff has officially stopped caring
about me and speaking of not caring
about me look who's back look who's back
holding down its spot at number eight is
our old friend - Bom I feel like the day
we retired to BOM is the day when hot
ones fans are just gonna start cutting
up their spice Lords t-shirts and
burning effigies of a bald guy and a
hoodie I do not want that day to come I
do not want that smoke just yet
so - Bom holds its spot at number eight
but look it we've got a new one at
number nine from a creepy ass clown and
season six - a Medusa like spice vixen
in season seven we're keeping the number
nine spot weird as ever with burns and
McCoy's ex her ESCO straight out of Fort
Collins Colorado as you know we've had
plenty of good times hitting our guests
with Carolina Reaper body blows over the
years but this time around we wanted to
spotlight and new one of the super hot
sand that's 7 pop primo which averages
more than 1.5 million scovilles if our
guests haven't had their taste buds
completely burned off at this point they
might be able to pinpoint some
thoughtful ingredients like oak aged
apple cider vinegar and yuzu juice all
right hot ones fans at the top of spice
Mountain the spicy piece de la
resistance the bottle shaking moment of
truth the last Debra ducks rides again
with its diabolical combination of
chocolate pepper axe and pepper axe and
here is the exciting news for months
people have been clamoring how do I get
my hands on the last dab redux if you
have a subscription box then you got
your bottle but thankfully there's now a
large enough pepper X crop for the last
dab producs wide release on October 11th
mark your calendars spice Lords October
11th the last dab
ducks available for wide release and
have another exciting day to announce
October 4th season seven of hot ones
premieres were back on October 4th
October 11 for the sauce
October 4th for the show sometime in the
fall for the classic November maybe
thank you for rocking with us through
season 1 season 2 season 3 season 4
season 5 season 6 and now into season 7
we'll see you next week over I didn't
break anything
hmmm middle times is an amazing turkey
leg and their tomato soup these ones
it's fine until you talk mm-hmm it's
good thing we made an interview show
around this you know million to 1
million three that's pretty good form
Phil did you get that cool shirt you
didn't hear how ones merch it's
available now I thought you only wore
Where's Waldo shirts I used to wear
where all their shirts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one
[Music]